Explanation based learning is a very common classroom task, you and
I appear to do it all the time. We can use a chair to prop open a door, and
we can deliver a very quick explanation for why the chair is a good prop.
We can use a coffee mug to hold down a pile of papers, and
pull out an explanation for why the coffee mug would make a good paper weight.
Of course there is a lot more to it than we have discussed sso far.
Explanation based learning is central [INAUDIBLE] on cognitive science, because
we are trying to build human like, human level intelligence. Explanations and
explanation based learning nowhere is prominent in other schools of AI.
Second, note that humans are not very good at explaining everything.
We can only explain those things which appear to be consciously accessible.
We have a hard time explaining memory processes, for
example, or we have a hard time explaining certain kinds of physical actions.
For example, when I play tennis, my feet move the way they do, and
I can't explain to you why I can't make them move better. Third, although we
can generate explanations, this does not necessarily mean that our process for
generating explanation is the same process that we use to arrive at the decision
in the first place. Explanations can be post talk. Further, the very act
of [UNKNOWN] explanations could interfere with the reasoning process.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
However, when we can generate explanations, it can lead to much deeper,
much richer understanding and learning,
because it exposes the cause of connections. Finally, for AI systems to be
accepted in our society they must be able to generate good explanations. You,
for example, will be unlikely to accept the advice of a medical
diagnostic system if the diagnostic system cannot explain it's answers.
I must be able to explain it's answers as well as the process it used to
arrive at those answers. Explanation is fundamental to trust.